Well, we had shown a couple years ago on
efforts we did with these was that we
could develop synthetic biology-based
sensors to detect viral pathogens such
as Ebola. In this case we took that
platform and now developed several dozen
sensors they could be used to detect Zika in a very rapid and inexpensive
manner. We took on the Zika challenge
largely because of the growing global
health crisis. Increasingly, we're seeing
reports in the media and the call for
new technologies. We have a synthetic
biology platform for rapid, cheap
diagnostics that was remarkably well-
suited to take on this crisis. So, Zika virus is an RNA virus which basically means
that its genome that it's carrying
around inside has RNA in it.
The idea is that we create a RNA-based sensor
and then you hydrate it with a simple and
then depending on if the Zika virus is
present or not then there's a color change
and you can easily see it with the naked
eye.
The standard way to diagnose these kinds of
viruses is an antibody-based method,
but one problem is that the antibodies that
you get once you get Zika virus are very
similar to the ones that you get for
Dengue. The nice thing about our method is
that it's a sequence-based method. We
initially looked at sequences of the
Zika virus from the field and we could actually identify
regions of the RNA genome that lent
themselves to the RNA-based sensors that
we've developed in the context of our
synthetic biology platform. We then went to
the next step and developed a whole
workflow, figuring out how you could process
patient samples. First of all, you start with
a patient sample, and then you
amplify it. That creates many many copies
of a small part of the Zika genome.
The concentration of the virus in the blood
is very very low. By doing an
amplification step where you're gonna try to just
increase the number of RNA molecules, that
now makes it easier to actually detect
the presence of such RNA and get a
measurable read-out where you could, for
example in our paper based scheme, see a change in
color. We use this amplified RNA, put
it on paper and test whether the virus
is present or not. Typically within 30
minutes to an hour you can start seeing
a color change on the paper, but if a
more precise measurement needs to be
made you can also transfer this paper
under an electronic reader that can take very
precise measurements and more
efficiently diagnose the Zika. As part of this
project in addition to direct detection
we also developed a platform that allows
us to discriminate between different
strains of the virus. Differences between the
RNA sequences of the different strains
tend to be very very small. What the
CRISPR system allows us to do is to
distinguish between those very small
differences. So you can discriminate to
identify: is it an African strain or is it
an American strain or an Asian strain. The
broader implications of what we have
here, whether it's for Zika or Ebola, or other viral infections is that
we have now a platform
that allows you to rapidly develop new
sensors for new outbreaks. We anticipate
that this platform will enable one to
actually develop, test, validate, and
deploy a new diagnostic in under a week.